so we've just got the elected members
remuneration paper in front of us
just as a brief update to that before we
um get into the recommendations is that
we've had a counselor only session
recently uh some members were not at
that
so uh the paper gives us three options
but we did consider a fourth option for
those who weren't here or those who
might want to scribble it down Ria and
others I'll just give you what the
fourth option was which was
um definitely me at 63
000.
cheers at fifty four thousand six
hundred
the lead role at 52 000 in councilors at
forty two thousand so I guess that's
option
four or option D
option four
Tommy I add something to that [ __ ]
because it does not add up exactly to
the rim pill it's a little bit below it
so you know there's I think there's a
few hundred dollars so my proposal would
be a few hundred dollars just gets split
equally amongst the 12 members
well the the other option Thomas is that
we've got a sort of an order mount for
the chairs if you have a look at me
we've got to sell good browsers nice
thing rounded up so but Michael would do
something in their space anyway there's
lots of options available yeah with
those numbers as long as we end up at
that figure yeah that's the only
requirement from the enumeration
Authority
so it would be helpful to start with for
somebody to recommend we receive this
report
and then we're going to determine which
of the options if anyone that we want to
uh yeah thank you rangi thank you grant
so the issue now is to open up the
debate for the options that we have in
front of us and potentially other
options as well
um
yeah oh I just uh had a quick look
through this and I'm sort of thinking
option two is the preferred option for
me because I think
cheers do quite a bit on the side
um similar to the to the deputy mirror I
think so and they're quite close
together those two numbers
so I think that's uh my preferred option
option two
not sorry you're through um cheers to me
yeah sorry oh sorry yeah sorry yeah
what he was saying I I suggest option
four uh the reason I'm suggesting that
is because it's done to a formula it's
not just done for a figure that's put
down it's a sort of a formula behind it
yeah Tom can you can you just help those
that weren't here so options one two and
three are seem to me to be relatively
subjective yep um it's not obvious how
the numbers were arrived at
um so therefore how do you resolve to on
any particular one
um option four is based on a formula
it's based on choosing the
um best salary for a counselor and then
applying a 1.3 fight to to the uh chairs
and a 1.5 factor to the mayor
um the 10 000 dollars for the project
manager you know as a relatively
arbitrary number it's not based on a a
factor
um so option four
um which comes basically line between
option one and option two
um is based on those ratios
um and it's two things it's based on
those ratios and it's based on the
um best seller for the counselor of 42
000. so if you take forty two thousand
multiply by 1.3 you come up with the
number for the chair multiplied by 1.5
you come up with a number for the deputy
mayor
um why did I propose that because that's
how it would normally be done in a
commercial board
um rather than I think relatively
subjective numbers that we we had in
number one two and three clip and just
um just I'm just yeah I understand the
differentials I understand how you've
applied it I think it's sorry for you
yeah
um I understand how you've applied it I
really it seems considerably more
logical than me rather than just
plucking out arbitrary numbers
um in my experience from previous terms
being in that um Deputy role and
understanding not DVD me sorry Deputy of
Cheers so what are the four
um my understanding was here like the
workload was significantly different
there were
um
moderately more meetings than you would
need to attend so like having that sort
of differential is I think but in a more
scientific manner I think is yeah like
I'd happily support that
just as a reflection I think it Alex it
it saves us getting through this
personalized stuff that you get into
every time we get this equation we'll
get it every time if we had a formula it
makes it really easy I was quite
surprised um on a personal level
um I I would have had the cheers one
thousand dollars more and
the lead drop back three
um but I was quite surprised that the
chairs were actually supported of the
lead having the extra money
um recent developments and when we get
to the calcium time shortly you'll
realize that the museum project is going
to get a massive job for somebody
so
any further debate or discussion yeah
rangi well it's just really a comment
when I when I first joined Council on
210
um
it was 40 20. counselors with 20 grand
chairs were 40 Grand so you know we've
come a long way and the logic I'm a man
of science and and as with Alex I agreed
that formula has has give us everything
credibility
yeah
no other hands up
Hands Up For What well yeah
no no no no I'm just saying no further
debate or anybody wanting to explore
things
actually
um
thanks I I
um would support option four I don't
think a bit of science behind it makes a
bit of sense and as long as we
um come to the correct figure at the end
I'm happy to
know if that will received the report
and go with option four is outlined up
by councilor Campbell excellent
any further discussion
yeah but that always a favor
um anybody opposed
excellent
business sir excuse me chair just a
point of administration we just need to
receive the apologies from councilors
Skelton sopa
I'm sorry that was Mark rumors on me
thank you
I'll move some apologies yeah
Mary singing it thank you
somebody like to move into public
excluder now yeah I'll move there yeah
so
just for benefit of staff that are
present that's also staff excluded as
well